what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
november the 1st we did it the joint is
brought to you by one of my all-time
[__] favorites liquid iv listen it's
the time of the year we're back in the
[__] gym we're trying to get
healthy we're trying to get our bodies
tip top magoo flu season is here so you
got to stay dry hydrated to support your
immune system adding one stick of liquid
iv to 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water alone
let me explain something to you when i'm
in the gym i drink a pre-workout
but while i'm at the gym you're [__]
sweating you're running you're doing all
this stuff you're lifting you're pulling
i drink liquid iv my favorite flavor is
guava i love it you put one package with
16 ounces of water as you're working out
you get thirsty that's what yeah i drink
it's healthier than those sugary sports
drink no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple can a core a apple no you can you
can't beat it it's made with non-gmo
vegan
gluten free dairy free and soy free and
as far as a company liquid iv tremendous
they're re-supporting front line workers
to stay healthy liquid iv has donated to
hospitals
food banks veterans and active military
military 11 million servings donated and
counting listen to me this is the future
i don't know what they've done over at
liquid iv their immune support is
tremendous so what i'm going to do is
this
just for the joint listeners
grab your favorite liquid iv mine
are tangerine and guava the guava is my
all-time favorite they're all over there
at walmart or you get them delivered
like i do get 25 percent off when you go
to liquidity.com
again that's
liquidity.com that's 25 off use code
joey at checkout that's 25 of anything
you order get better hydration today by
using promo code joey and go to liquid
iv.com try the guava it just knocks the
cuban out of me you understand me
tremendous
the joint is also brought to you by
draftking is one of my all-time
favorites i've fallen in love with
draftkings from the social network on
there to the casino i love their
football blackjack and they have great
lines they make great payouts this
weekend i got some action for you it
starts tonight tonight you got the new
york giants
versus the kansas city chiefs
in kansas city i don't know what the
line is but listen do what you need to
do there's money right in the paper
remember home team underdog on a monday
night small parlays draftkings has it
all same game paul a's
this week we got ufc 268. joey what does
that mean five dollars can net you 200
with any draft king sports book the
nigerian nightmare and chaos square off
at madison square garden let me explain
something to you did you hear what i'm
saying to you
usman versus kobe you got listen you got
a a hell of a lot of fights on here
you've got
green versus ali kinta oh my god justin
gagey against chandler
edgar against marvin vera listen to me
it's money time ching ching did you hear
that new customers bet five dollars on
either fighter and if you win you get
200 miles and free bets listen to me
guys i love draftkings i swear to god i
was with a couple different
other services before draftkings let me
tell you something that second to none
they had a thing during the world series
i was just work i was just
getting 25 a night you were i think out
of this games i bet
the first to score you don't have to say
if it was houston or
[__] atlanta just first to score
there's a score on the first inning it's
the world series it's gonna be under the
defense was low i went under a couple
nights even though i went over but the
guaranteed lock was always the score i
think only in game
five did they didn't score four they did
not score on the first any but anyway
who cares draftkings is safe secure
reliable and best of all you can
withdraw your cash whenever you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey and start
tonight with the giants at kansas city
throw down five dollars this weekend on
ufc 268 main event usman versus kobe and
if you win 200 miles and free bets if
your fighter wins that's five dollars to
win 200 dollars that's a [__] deal
all right that's code joey this saturday
at draftkings don't forget you got nba
basketball you got hockey you got
college football college basketball's on
the way you got to be 21 year old you're
21 older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
connecticut tennessee denver new
customers only minimum
five dollar deposit
and one dollar wager required one per
customer don't try to be cute
[__] restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportbook for details now
if you've got a gambling farm
call 1-800 gambler but if you're
straight and you're ready to go it's the
holiday season [__] it's time to
make some guitars download the draftking
sportsbook app or the fantasy app and
let's make some [__] money the
joint is also brought to you by the best
in the business zip recruiter they're
[__] amazing you could do anything
with just one click of the button you
could use the little finger to call your
girlfriend order delivery and even a
therapy session and now you could do
even more with one click like find the
job that you love let me tell you
something
zip recruiter has a lot of jobs on there
i don't know if you're looking for a job
or not i put in a [__] mooc resume
that i want you know and they've sent me
jobs every day
just amazon alone when you create a free
profile with zip recruiter they send you
jobs that match your skills and
experience you can apply to most jobs
that zip recruiter sends you with just
one quick one click
no more filling out lengthy applications
it's that easy that's why zip recruiter
is the number one rated job site in
america by g2 i've been talking about
zip recruiter for years now it's your
time to act if you're looking for a
great job ziprecruit has got your answer
sign up for free today with
ziprecruiter.com
slash easy capital e a s y that's easy
because it's [__] easy it's reliable
and it's great i wish i could show you
my phone
zip recruiter sends me emails every
10 look i just got two more
new jersey tom vista mjl police athletic
league recruitment police athletically i
need this job right now i think this is
the staten island working with kids and
[__] i would love to staten island yep
the police athletic league is the
largest and i need a job so that's why
i'm selling you go to ziprecruiter.com
slash easy right now to sign up
absolutely free
put zip recruiting this work for you
let's get this party started it's monday
november 1st we're starting the month
and the week on one day i love you
come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's a beautiful [__] monday to be
alive welcome to the joint it's november
1st i am [__] fired the [__] up
it's official getting ready for 20 22
days that's what you do man that's it if
you're not getting ready for january and
february and what the [__] you're gonna
do
you're slipping but who gives a [__] it
was a great weekend i hope you had a
great halloween
let me tell you something i was watching
tv two nights ago
just minding my business you know at the
end of the day you just put the [__]
tv on and i'm not talking about politics
here i don't eat the guys that think i'm
political whatever there's an election
tomorrow for some of you people who live
in a [__] cave whatever you know
murphy in jersey and new york's looking
for a new [__] mayor right they're
dying to get this de blasio out so
they're down to two guys they're down to
his brother eric whatever next cop
you could tell he's [__] a savage and
he's down to
curtis silva or silva
curtis silver for a lot of people you
don't know is the president of the
[__] guardian angels this guy has
been [__] lurking in new york since i
was a kid this guy tried to [__] up my
parades all the time because
we used to go to [__] harlem the cop
the dealers would be hold on we got the
guardian angels to hurt her and i'm like
who gives a [__] they're a bunch of guys
with a whistle it's not like they could
arrest your [__] who gives a [__] you
know the spanish dealers never gave a
[__] but like the white dealers up and
harlem and [__] would always give you a
hard time like all right nothing's going
on the guardian angels are around i
[__] hate the guardian angels in all
my life but let me tell you something
about curtis silva
that [__] has been beat up god
he shot him like one of god these people
i think shot him they beat him up
something happened you got to check it
out on wikipedia something happened but
he's running for mayor tomorrow right
tomorrow's the election
and he's over there campaigning on
[__] saturday this is what i saw
yesterday right i was [__] dying i
was watching the nfl and then the news
came on whatever the you know the late
game last night and the news came on and
the next thing you [__] know
they're like curtis silva didn't take
the day off whatever his name is don't
quote me on the name curtis silva didn't
take the day off he's out campaigning
and you see him inside like a fire
department
and he's talking to the fire department
he's telling them listen if i'm the
mayor there'll be no mandates and
they're just looking at them like
curtis come on guy there's like three
firemen listening to them the rest of
them are mopping
they don't give a [__] like nobody's
paying attention but the best shot they
showed was
he got hit by a car on saturday
some taxi cab hit and run curtis silva
now listen let me explain something to
you i'm no [__] genius here but i
take messages from the universe okay
if i get hit by a cab on a [__]
satellite before the election on tuesday
and the guy doesn't even stop for the
next mayor in new york i'm not saying
he's gonna win i'm just saying you're
driving down the street right
you know and all of a sudden you're like
[__] it's a beautiful day to be alive
the sun goes in your eyes you bump you
hit somebody right you look it's the
guardian angels the guy that's running
for mayor and you're like you know
somebody would go oh my god he's running
for mail let me pull over this whoever
hit him was like [__] this dude like he
ain't running this is horrible they hit
him with the [__] car he went down
went to the hospital but here he is
campaigning now when i was growing up
curtis silva whatever his [__] name
is sweewa i don't know he had like you
know her uh guardian angels they had to
be 30 [__] dudes
a couple white dudes a couple black
dudes they were yolked
you know they were young they were
walking around like they were [__]
you know into it
they showed him
with
that like like curtis silver's whatever
[__] campaign
and they actually showed this poor
bastard
and he's down to like three little
skinny crackheads
like they couldn't protect themselves
three little skinny dudes like you know
i'm saying and he was holding on to them
he's got the [__] arm where she got
hit by the cab so he got the arm it's
busted and he's like i'm curtis siva and
i'm running for you don't forget to come
on vote for me in the polls let me tell
you something i got to be honest with
you i got the felonies and [__] but
right when i finish this podcast i'm
calling my attorney because i'm voting
for him because he needs every vote he
could get if i'm going to goof on him he
earns my [__] vote i ain't voting for
a governor i ain't voting for nobody but
i'm voting for this guy because if he
gets 13 votes
that'll be a lot you know what i'm
saying like you ever see somebody like
god damn that poor bastard if he gets 12
votes like his mother's gonna vote for
him his grandmother you know like an
uncle that's in prison [__] like that
that's who's gonna vote for that poor
bastard he ain't got a suit on his shirt
is sloppy
his beret got dirt on it come on curtis
give me a [__] break man i mean i
don't like to ruin piss on people's legs
or [__] cancel somebody's parade but
i got a better chance of running for man
i guarantee i would get one more vote
than curtis silva i'd get like 15 16
votes but i'd be happy that's my
expectation let me tell you a little
[__]
let me tell you a little guardian angel
story right in
2005. you know the longest yard comes
out right i don't know nothing about
nothing i've never been in a big movie
i'm just a i'm a cokehead i'm [__]
just a dirty comic and [__] and i'm in
this [__] feature and everybody's
talking about there's billboards and i'm
in the trailer and [__]
so the first weekend i picked for the
longest yard was jersey city there used
to be a club in jersey city called
bananas
they're still around they're in like uh
are they still out i don't even [__]
know i don't [__] know if they're
still around i think oh no no no no it
was rascals in jersey city
rascals used to be in west orange and
off uh rascal shore
and then this guy bought the rascals so
he added one in jersey city and one in
some part of boston that that that shut
down in a week i think they lit it on
fire
they don't have comedy in that side of
boston you know what i'm saying so this
guy opened up a club in jersey city
i figured out a respect the closest to
north bergen is [__]
jersey city so i did the
the weekend i did one show friday one
show saturday nobody came to see me you
know just people that are going to vote
for me in the mayoral election i had
like 30 people 15 on [__] friday
and 15 on saturday no big deal so i
wanted to promote it
so my friend got me uh i was never on
their radar you know at all i knew jim
norton from opening for andrew
so he got me a spot on opie and anthony
i was [__] thrilled like stern
wouldn't take me nobody would take me
but opie and anthony will
so i
go to opiate athlete now the best thing
about going to opiate anthony is when
you walk out of there there's a hot dog
stand up the [__] corn i love that
[__] by the avenue the americas there's
always a guy even when you go there
[__] early like you go to seven in
the morning there's a [__] hot dog
guy up there like when you go in that
eight or something like that you'll hear
people arab people talking
that means they're selling gyros and
[__] already that's what it got they're
like on a [__] loudspeaker like
talking about gyro zahala
so i went up there i went i went in and
two doors down
from [__] opie and anthony in that
building it's not opium anthony it's
serious
two doors three doors down i saw club
soda kenny you know and uh he goes
there's a great [__] ham and egg
place over there so
you know what at the time of the longest
shot i'm 400 [__] pounds
why stop at a hot dog let me get four or
five hot dogs and i'll go over and get a
[__] you know taylor ham and egg on
the cheese you know what i'm saying i
mean that was my [__] breakfast at
that time
so i get out of opium anthony you know
and i walked to the [__] corner
and i
grabbed my two chili dogs at [__] 8
30 in the morning the fat [__] that i am
right
and i mean the two chili dogs and i
swear to god guys who comes up to me
but a skinny little brother
that's a guardian angel
right i mean you can't no i'm i don't
know if i'm hung
that
at that time ralphie may was doing
caroline's that weekend if you look it
up may of
2005 uh memorial day weekend ralphie was
doing
caroline's
so ralphie offered me
he got an extra hotel room
he goes i got an extra hotel room so you
could stay with me in the city i was
like [__] it
so i went to the city to stay with
ralphie and then
that morning i got up and i went to do
opiate anthony no big deal i go get my
[__]
two hot dogs and who jumps on me
but a skinny [__] uh african-american
dude nice brother you know a little he
wasn't all there
a guardian angel he's like what's
happening man he goes where are you
going you're in that movie and [__] and
i'm like yeah thank you i saw the movie
it's a [__] hit you're a killer i saw
you eight years ago and i always had
your back you know and i'm looking at
this guy like i wasn't even around that
years ago i know what the [__] you're
talking about eight years ago was 1997 i
was just doing [__] uh you know
feature sets up in
seattle or some [__] he's like telling
me i saw you in jersey you [__] hit
it out of the park and then he was
talking about rogan so i'm like oh this
guy got some credibility he has probably
seen me
and he's talking to me he's like you you
by yourself
and i'm like yeah i'm just walking over
to get an egg sandwich because you're
gonna eat two hot dogs and an egg
sandwich chubby you could eat and all
this [__] we're just going back and
forth
and he goes at the end of the thing goes
man you're by yourself you need security
like a what
and he goes you need security man you're
a movie star my god jesus christ i'm no
[__] movie star i thought about that
kevin hart bit where he talks about
security you know like he needed
security he don't need rock security he
needs security for people who like
[__] spit on glass and go ah when
he's eating at a restaurant and all that
[__] that's me i don't need no [__]
what i need to say nobody even [__]
talks to me he goes you need security
man these are my [__] digits
i'm an expert in kung fu gung-fu
[__] dog this guy had a list
that did not [__] stop he hit me with
20 different
karate styles that he knew and [__] like
that and then to top it off
he [__] started doing moves on the
street guys
you don't know what embarrassing is
when there's a skinny guy doing bruce
lee moves on the [__] street in front
of you and people are looking at you and
you're like oh this is not happening so
i go listen i gotta go i gotta go dog
things are happening let me walk you to
port authority i'm like listen i'm cool
i'm gonna take a cab i was flat [__]
broke
like i had maybe 20 bucks i was gonna
take a bus over but i didn't give a [__]
i had to get away from this guy because
he was just embarrassing me doing
sidekicks he started stretching to show
me how [__] whatever he was and i
said hey listen i gotta run i gotta go
do this and this let me come with you no
you listen you can't i work security for
free let me do you a day for free and if
you like me you pay me if not i'm like
listen it was like those
disco mixtapes you know these brothers
that come up to you and they give you a
mixtape here you go man you're like
what's this it's my mixtape you want to
donate some money not really i wasn't
looking to donate dick today i'm not
looking for any [__] rap albums last
time last rapport i bought was biggie
ready to die and last time i checked you
ain't [__] biggie you know what i'm
saying so get the [__] i mean they even
do that [__] to you and they come up to
you and put the cd in
so this guy kept [__] going kept
going kept going kept going i'm like you
know what
i gotta go guy so he gave me his number
he's like take my digits and [__] you
know what i'm saying i'm like oh
and he saw that i had a cell phone i'm
like god damn it because at that time i
had a pager i was very happy with my
page when i had a page and nobody would
ask me for my [__] number
they'd see the page and go we don't want
your number you're low rent that's how i
want i don't want to give out my number
but he saw i had a cell phone
and he goes let me let me get your
number let me so i gave him my [__]
number that was a mistake guy
every day he called me so i flipped it
on him i did a joey diaz
i started torturing the [__] hey
man what are you doing do you have a
bazooka
and he would go no why you need one i'm
doing a show up in brooklyn and the
[__] the mafia is coming and i
i just would blow smoke up his ass
and i would give him a [__] date and
he'd [__] call me two days later and
go what the [__] happened to you i
waited i was at the gramercy hotel i was
waiting there with three [__]
killers to do security for you and i'm
like i'm sorry the plane got delayed so
i did that to him like six times before
he caught on and he disappeared from my
life and life went on but that's that's
my guardian angel story this guy
tortured me for at least a [__] year
and i finally went you know what
i got to get rid of this guy to my life
he would call me at 2 in the morning
four in the morning six in the morning
so i started just calling him going hey
you know cleveland yeah there's a club
called [__] the matador there's no
club called the matador
and he would [__] go all right i'm
gonna get my partners and go down and
then he would call me back i looked in
the yellow pages there ain't no matador
i'm like no i said metaphor you know and
he would [__] call me back metaphor i
can't find club metaphor this went on
until he finally just i i told him to go
to pennsylvania to wix barry i swear to
god i go meet me at wilkes-barre
pennsylvania friday night
we're doing the [__] theater there
there's no [__] d today i just made
up a name linda rowe a booker a great
lady used to book a room up there like a
barn and i had the itinerary and when he
called me i was looking to give him i
just go just [__] meet me at this
barn that was where i sent him the last
time he called me i'm like i'm here i'm
surrounded by white [__] and
[__] up here in pennsylvania there's
amish
i said i don't know what to tell you
they never called me the [__] back and
that was the end of my experience
with the guardian [__] angels so i
don't know if you're going to vote
monday i don't even know why i went into
this [__] story it's monday morning
we got to talk we got to talk about what
the [__] is cracking in the news the
other thing i saw this weekend which was
very [__] impressive
this is the [__] i like guys i i don't
know about you guys
you know i really don't care about the
ufos in new jersey i mean i gotta be
honest with you guys
i'm to a point in my life and it's not a
point in my life it's a if i say that to
you i'm wrong this is the way i've
always been
i've always been i've always been a fan
of rocky stories
in any
situation
in any situation at all i've always been
a sucker for that [__]
you know when i was a kid
i was watching tv one day i was watching
college football i didn't even know what
the [__] college basketball i didn't
even know what i was watching
and i saw a [__] kid and he was from
jersey city he was a freshman he was
starting
and he inspired me you know what i'm
saying when i was uh
a freshman in high school i went to see
a kid play basketball
and he [__] uh
scored 68 points and he broke
you know uh
my man's record out of union city saint
michael's uh the the announcer of the
celtics
and i was very inspired you know like
that
i get inspired from uh rag to rich's
story you know a lot of people get
inspired by [__] uh you know
marvel or you know they stand online for
spider-man you know
i i've never really that's my main thing
i like reading books that
you know like lee iacocca's book uh
the crazy guy from texas book the guy
that ran for president i became a fan of
his
i like reading
stories of struggle
i love struggle you know i
i see a beauty and struggle i really do
i rather uh you know i see the beauty of
miss pat's story
i see the beauty in my story you know
sometimes when i feel down about myself
or something's got going on or
i can't make a decision about something
you know i i'm not the the number one uh
i'm not the best
what's that [__] like i don't think the
best of myself you know and a lot of
people have noticed that over the years
i i break my
my balls i i don't think the best of
myself you know like and whenever i do
get into those funks
i think about success stories people who
have applied themselves people who have
said you know what this is what i'm
gonna do
come hella high water and guess what
i don't have the winds behind me
see when somebody goes for something
like i like to talk to you in a comedy
sense or in a sports sense but
people would take this the wrong way
when i see it
i appreciate
gabriel glacier story more than let's
say
i don't know
i i don't know but i don't even know
another comic i i was there with gabriel
i saw gabriel start
as a 17 year old kid
you know a lot of people [__] hit me
up sometimes you know jerk off people
and they'll go hey man you're retweeting
this guy are you retweeting that guy
you're retweeting this guy's date he's
not funny this guy's not funny she's not
funny people always got their own
opinion of who's not funny or whatever
when i retweet these people
i personally think they're funny
or personally
i think they're amusing i don't think
they're [__] the funniest person in
the world i don't think that my [__]
you know
but i know their story
you know what i'm saying like i know
their [__] story
and their story
makes me
want to stand behind them
just because you don't know that [__]
story
doesn't mean you know there's no [__]
i i love camaraderie i love supporting
people
but i also love the story i i [__] do
my dick gets hard when i found out that
you know doug stanhope was living in his
car when he won the san francisco comedy
competition
did you know that story that the night
of the final somebody broke in his car
and stole all his [__] clothes
and every possession that he had and he
still went up there
and destroyed that [__] room and won
first place and beat [__] i mean look
it up he'd be dane cook he'd be
i think rob i don't even know vinnie
favorito don't quote but i know it's
dane cook and somebody else
that doug stanhope doug stanhope could
could [__] run somebody over with a
car
he could hamper his career whatever he
could pull an oj and i will still
respect somebody like doug stanhope
because i know the work he put in
to his career you know what i'm saying
like you respect those people
like i saw doug go in a car and [__]
put a pole in the back of the car and
hang his clothes back there and he went
on the road and he dedicated himself to
this and not once did he come to me and
go you know i don't have enough
instagram friends or
he just put his head down and went those
are the people that inspired me when i
see a guy like ralphie may
who
dog rafi was a funny comic funny as [__]
great guy
worked hard taught me a different level
of work ethic than joe rogan taught me
joe rogan's got a great work ethic but
ralphie may had a complete different
work ethic and i took a little from his
work but let me tell you something bro
let's get an example here tiffany
haddish
ralphie may
tiffany haddish had been busting her ass
since 2000 [__] three i know for a
fact
that's how long i know tiffany haddish
when i say busting her ass i'm saying
busting her ass on a tuesday night
babysitting to make money for rent and
then running down and doing a spot at
the comedy store on a black show and you
know she wasn't well known people didn't
receive her much
she was a woman a female she would get
on late you know when i see tiffany
haddish i love tiffany haddish i
communicate with tiffany haddish every
two weeks on a text i'm watching you
girl
because i was there i saw tiffany had
his sharing it apart i remember when
tiffany haddish lived in [__] ontario
to save money ontario california for you
people don't know that's an hour and a
half to two hours all day long from
hollywood
no matter what time it [__] is
and she would bust her [__] hump you
know there's a there's a difference
between making it and there's a
difference between making it
when you have no [__] sales behind
your back when there's nobody helping
you and there's nobody pushing you
ralphy may i was there with him in those
meetings i was there driving him to
those meetings when he would come out
and with a [__] face and his cheeks
were red and you could see he was deeply
[__] upset and they would tell him no
because he was too fat
ralphie had a battle and a [__] half
everybody kept telling him you're too
fat you're too fat you know who didn't
mitchy sure
that's who didn't tell him he's too fat
she put him right up there on the stage
and i gotta be honest with you jamie
masada gave him a ton of [__] love no
matter how big he was so when you see
there's certain comics that they get to
la and they got everything pointed at
them they're good looking
you know a manager signed him right off
the bat hari came down last weekend me
and i were talking to them like all
right you know what the best thing about
us was
they were all against us for years they
were all against the state haters
and we [__] them up they had to sniff
our dick at the end of the [__] at
the end of it all they had to suck a
[__] dick
even though they hated us why does rogan
bring him on the road so i always love
it when an underdog an underdog underdog
underdog who's busted his [__] hump
for years and has been told no no no no
i love it when they [__] come through
you have no idea and even if listen
even if they don't stay with that
[__] tower that position it doesn't
matter
they reached the goal they were
intending to reach
and it's over
you guys are talking to me like joy what
the [__] are you talking about what are
you getting there what's this [__]
ear beating you're giving us why are you
putting us through this torture listen
to me i was watching i want i didn't
know what time the ufc game came on the
fight the other day
i didn't have time to bet it i wasn't
gonna bet it or not like that i had
taken my daughter to kick boxing
i had to take it to this halloween thing
i had to run some errands and i come
home and a friend of mine calls me and
invites me some things saturday night
and he goes i don't know i invited you
because
the ufc is in the daytime i didn't think
you'd do it in the nighttime like what
do you mean the ufc in the daytime he
goes yeah they're fighting in abu dhabi
so the [__] card starts at like 10 in
the morning what the [__] it was about
lunch time i didn't know what guys this
is how out of a loop i am
so i [__] run to the tv i i you know
i'm searching for this [__] uh espn
it was a free fight everybody told me
it's a free fight it's a free fight it's
a free fight hurry up go watch a great
[__] card i wanted to watch those
khabib looking like cousins khabib must
have had three [__] cousins on there
yesterday chameleon kalikanov the other
guy with the beard they threw beatings
on [__] everybody i don't know i
don't i forget the country i'm not
trying to be insulting here it's like a
little part of russia towards the
underneath russia
banistan wherever he's from abdullah i
don't know but i'll tell you those
little [__] guys that khabib is
sending over about to unleash ass
whippings on this [__] ufc that
camille kid and listen i'm not good with
the names the one who big jinjing
that was [__] tremendous so i was you
know i was busy doing a couple things i
really wanted to watch the dan hooker
fight it was too late so i ended up
watching glover
against uh whatever now all week long
i'm not gonna lie to you
i thought global was old you know i like
globe i met global years ago
i didn't know he was 42. but i know
globe has been around uh
the globe for you know he's been in the
game for a long [__] time
i met him years ago you know i'm not
good friends when we met like hi how are
you very nice to meet you i'm a comedian
you're glover
you know yeah
what do i say to that guy you know
and i always knew he was uh
chuck ledell's training partner you know
chuck always spoke about him in
interviews and stuff like that it was
chuckle blew him up and you know so
getting to my point uh i'm not gonna lie
to you guys
friday night when i got home from
whatever the [__] i had to do i
went on draftkings
and i just wanted to see who was
fighting what the what the card was i i
i had my whole
i had the weeks confused frankie edgar
is this [__] week
with ufc and [__] msg that's a great
[__] card but anyway i don't want to
get ahead of myself
i'm watching uh
i go let me sit down let me look at this
card and i actually went to see what
blankowicz i think that's his name who
fought to share
i wanted to see what he would pay to win
and it was like
20 [__] bucks
and if i bet dan hooker i would have won
a lot of [__] like i don't know if i
bet 50 bucks on van hooker i would have
won 125 but if you bet
50 on the kid he fought i swear to god
it was like take home 63 dollars i'm
like you know because with baseball and
like uh football you could bet 25 bucks
and win like you know 60 bucks 70 bucks
if you bet like a 25 dollar parley on
draftkings you get like 130 dollars
that's a [__] great deal i don't know
if you guys know a five-time paulet
is
no five time paul a 17 to lose
35 to win and then it's 70 to win
35 to lose with a 10-time [__] paul
that that guy's i'm i just know i've
been on draftkings so long i forget what
the [__] odds things are with the
regular book
but uh like if you bet a 25 on the paul
on draftkings you got like 93 [__]
dollars
that's not too [__] shabby you know
what i'm saying that's not too shabby
but
if you bet blanco it's whatever his name
is uh against [__] glover it was like
63 bucks the same with the kid who
fought the money line the same with the
kid who fought
dan hooker and there was another fight i
looked at it was the same thing so i got
there's really no money in this [__]
fight so i'm not gonna sit here and put
myself through hell to
to [__] bet this [__]
so i turned on the [__] fight and i
gotta tell you man i watched
glovatoshera
and i said let me let me watch this this
is an interesting [__] fight here
and i felt kind of shitty for even uh
you know like pussing on on blankowicz
whatever his [__] name is to win i
just wanted to see what you know i don't
know if he was an underdog i
look when you get when you bet football
you're giving six and a half
three and a half two and a half you know
when you're betting those uh
ufc's it's more moneyline that's not my
i don't know much about moneyline joe
rogan knows a lot more about the money
line he could break it down for you i
cannot
understand the [__] money line so
forget about the money line who gives a
[__] about the money line i'm watching
this [__] fight
and next thing you know glovatoshara
takes the guys back and he wins he taps
them out with a rear naked choke
i gotta be honest with you
my insides broke my eyes swole a little
bit
i was not expecting that
i didn't know what to expect
from glover
you know from the minute i turned it on
glover was having his [__] way with
him so i didn't really [__] know what
to
think of the fight but when glover
tapped him out and he got up
and i looked in his face i gotta be
honest with you guys
i fell for the [__] guy
i was happy
i turned the tv off and it made me want
to get in the car and take a [__]
ride i was thinking about it
you know these are the things i like i
love [__] rocky stories you know i
love rocky man that's my [__] movie
if rocky's on i'm watching i know that
right now rocky re-released rocky iv the
one with drago i think they that's what
he's calling it drago or whatever and
you can't even get tickets for it they
were showing it in philly the other
night [__] sold out like [__]
eight screenings of drago and they want
like 20 bucks i mean they're not [__]
around so
i was like damn people love rocky sure
they do
we're [__] americans man we love that
story we love listen i'm gonna tell you
something this times i feel shitty about
myself
like i'm not doing anything with my life
you know the felonies i lost the
daughter
i think about a lot of crazy [__] at
times and i gotta tell you something
then i think about my life and i go you
know what
i did everything i wanted to [__] do
i really did i had my daughter
i have a wife you know we're happy i
mean i don't [__] jump up and down on
top of her she doesn't have to beat me
the [__] up we giggle we
we laugh we go to stupid [__] things
as far as comedy is concerned listen
guys
i [__] did when i
i wish
they wouldn't have towed my car remember
the apartment they towed on me like i
had this [__] car i parked it outside
my [__] girlfriend's house and they
told it i owe like 800 [__] tickets i
didn't have the registration it wasn't
my registration the girl had to pay for
it
i still feel awful about it i should
look her up and try to give her a couple
[__] yardsticks
but they took my notebooks
i would pay
i don't know a thousand bucks one of
those notebooks today
because there was one notebook that was
what i was thinking you know my car got
towed in 98.
so
that car had my thoughts from the very
early beginning of what i was thinking
in l.a you know
i never wanted to be a [__] star
i never wanted to be
like on hbo i swear to god like i didn't
expect any of this [__] there was no
netflix when i started none of that [__]
was around
i just wanted to prove my point
what was my point that i could do this
and who was i proving it to let me
explain something i was proving it to a
couple [__]
[__] you know like um when i first
started comedy not many in boulder i
could say there was a lot there weren't
many just people who made [__] little
remarks
but the people i really wanted to
[__]
prove my point to
was all the scumbags in l.a all the
[__] know-it-alls guys if you ever
get into comedy or acting
or writing or anything to do in the
entertainment business and you end out
dealing with agents and
people who have control over your
decisions
don't let them
[Music]
get you down with their little listen
all those people
never got to reach their [__] goals
think about it they never got their
they're in a r and they're 24. show me
what band they [__] created
what led zeppelin band that they [__]
put together
and they're going to come and tell you
what you should do and we should wear
and then you get down on yourself from
what some [__] 28 year old
that never did what you're even trying
to accomplish
he probably had a rich mom and dad who
sent them to [__] college they went
up to syracuse
and got a degree and whatever now he's
walking around with this [__]
attitude with his little fake [__]
hairdo and the one earring in one ear to
seem really cool so you're [__]
impressed and he maybe gets a guns and
roses tattoo which blows you the [__]
way apart but that guy's got control
over your life only if you let him
only if you let him that's when you
start proving your [__] point
and i don't want you to go back and
knock on his door and say [__] you [__]
i told you i knew it no no no
a wink is as good as a knot to a blind
[__] horse
a wink is as good as a nod you know how
the other great time i had
the last [__] seven years in la
because i had to go work for people who
told me i sucked
i had to work for people told me i was
too old i had to work for people who
told me i was too dirty
you're too dirty oh my god when i
when i you know look at this audience
look at this [__] audience are they
offended
[Music]
are they really offended you know
they're doing this thing on
the world series i know a lot of you
guys are watching it when you watch
atlanta they're like
you know they do that
and you know [__] everybody's like
all the liberal sports writers every day
atlanta's got to really get woke and all
this [__] [__] you let me tell you
something my wife is indian and the
other night it was on and we were
talking about it i go mercy look at
those people in fact me and my daughter
will sit there at night and go
with the tomahawks with you
we do it me and her do it my wife just
looks at us like what the [__]
my wife is a cherokee indiana you know
she's got friends of the [__] indians
her mother's a [__] indian and she's
got friends that are [__] indians
just for a goof last week i go honey let
me ask you guys you know i
i told my daughter that you can't
[__] do that [__] it's offensive you
know but we could do it in the [__]
house you know what i'm saying like
you know just do it in the [__] house
while watching the game for some fun
and i asked my wife i go do you get
offended by that she goes no i think
it's funny i go
do you like when you go home does your
mother say anything to you or your aunts
when you go to your [__] little
indian shing dingers in tennessee do you
guys sit there and talk about the
[__] braves and she goes no
no it's the [__]
what is the home of the free and the
land of the brave
right they're the braves all right that
has no joey what the [__] i got to do
with the indians but what i'm trying to
say is that think about it you know
they're telling you that it's offensive
like every time i hurt for like a week
i'm not gonna lie to you for like a week
maybe i don't know a month ago whenever
i saw the braves i'm like man there's an
indian at home no they're not you think
indians at home drinking [__] gin
going one of the braves gonna stop this
[__] you know what i'm saying i can't
get my life together while the brave
fans don't stop doing this [__]
so anyway they get back
on the stadium oh yeah they do it every
night in atlanta
they do it every [__] night in
atlanta they just go [__] off i mean
they just and they win it you know they
won i don't [__] know
it works but you know it was interesting
to ask my wife like can i talk you know
we talked
like i talked to her to her without my
daughter and then i spoke to her with my
daughter in the room but we got more
into it i think it was like a breakfast
one day we were into it and i go did
they ever like when you go to indian
things in college now
now
now nobody's ever said you know what we
got to write a letter to the atlanta
people they gotta stop that's just some
[__] imaginary person who throws that
out there like [__] you know it's
like uh
defund the police and it sticks
somebody actually [__] the word
[__] sticks but anyway going back for
what the [__] i was talking about here
proving your point is huge and when i
saw glover yesterday globe has had he's
15 and five in the [__] ufc
that's 20 fights
he's like 31 and 17 overall
you know that's like 50
[__] fights i've never gotten into 50
[__] arguments
none of my 50 [__] fights
you know like that's
he's 42 [__] years old and he finally
got the gold
that is just
it gives me hope in this shitty [__]
world
in this world right now with all the
[__] mandates and
you know uh
11 to 12 and you got to be a kid to take
this and if you take 600 out of the bank
they're going to charge you with taxes
and you know with all this [__] going on
in the world
with all this [__]
because it's all [__]
you know
with [__] people shooting people on
sets
with [__]
stewardesses getting [__] their faces
punched in did you see that [__] you
know with all this stupid [__] that's
going on in the world right now
to make to see someone being able to
prove their [__] point
just makes my [__] dick hard i swear
to god i was so happy last night i went
over to the pickled herring my favorite
jewish deli and i got a [__]
sprinkled cookie i swear to god i didn't
give a [__] about weight watchers i
didn't give a [__] about my points i
didn't give a [__] about anybody i did
go to the pickled hurry the pickled
herring is a [__] jewish deli
in [__] marlboro new jersey it
replaced another jewish deli that was
there me tell you something
i was there friday night for dinner with
jimmy florentine
i'm in that [__] joint all right
that's the first time i sat down for
dinner
my wife and my daughter went to
we went to a uh
a uh softball all-star [__] thing but
before that i had some time
and i had to do something oh we went to
the kids parade that's what it was me
and jimmy went over to the [__] kids
parade for halloween tremendous we saw i
thought there was nobody there i don't
think anybody works in this [__] area
or they were all there to see their
[__] kids
when i got there guys i thought there
was going to be like maybe 10 parents
everybody [__] works no [__] there
was not even parking spots on me and
[__] we didn't have the softball
dinner till seven so me and jimmy ran
over to the pickled herring oh my god i
got myself a nice pastrami with a
coleslaw he went in with a [__]
turkey and roast beef with french
dressing on rye it was like eight inches
[__] big jesus christ i love that
[__] place i love jewish delis in
this area there's the jewish bagel place
i don't know what they are they're the
pale jews they don't [__] around they
don't even serve me that [__]
you're not getting a slice of cheese in
there or nothing it's either white meat
or [__] tuna or egg salad plain and
simple they're on the [__] nine but
in marlborough if you're ever in the
marlboro area stop at the pickled
[__] herring get an egg salad
i'd taken rich boss there his [__]
yarmulke was spinning for an hour jack
let me tell you something i'm bringing
lee when the elite comes down to visit
me you don't think i'm taking him to the
pickled harry and you're out of your
[__] mind i take [__] everybody
there they got a square condition they
got a circle condition and they got a
square condition are you [__] kidding
me or what they got [__] egg salad
like on a kaiser roll with seeds hmm
they got [__] pastrami that's second
to none they got a great corned beef and
let me tell you something what i love my
favorite thing about that place is
they got every flavor wise potato chip
ever [__] invented sour cream and
onion
onion and garlic garlic by itself i saw
something that he had never even [__]
seen they got these little [__]
cookies they got the chinese cookie with
the black dot in the middle you know
what i'm talking about
oh with that black dotted fudge with
that little [__] i don't know i want
to say ginger but it's not [__]
ginger
i i get those they have the sprinkled
ones and then they have the chocolate
sprinkled ones come on jewish people
rise up [__] i got your [__]
deli you know uncle joey's looking out
for my [__]
jewish brothers and sisters the pickled
herring i i told when ari came hari
comes down and they get shiny because i
got a great little chinese joint they
got [__] genitals chicken that'll
make your head [__] blow up it's
[__] delicious but
the next time ari comes
i'm taking him over to the [__]
pickled herring he's gonna lose his
[__] mind but i'm in there two three
days a [__] week
there's a waitress there that confuses
me she's beautiful she's a sweetheart
she's blonde
she's i don't know she's jewish she's
got tattoos and every time i go in there
i'm like man
i don't know jewish people must be
looking at it like what the [__] you
know you're not gonna be able to get
buried in the jewish [__] cemetery
but every time i see her she's great she
tells me her son listens to the podcast
so i want to give him a [__] shout
out i don't know what your name is kid
but i love you you got a cool mom over
at the deli
but back to what i was talking about
before we wrap it up in this
[__] on a monday morning
november the 1st i am fired the [__] up
you're asking me joey why are you fired
up cause dawg we got a new set of goals
going up today
i love all this [__] i really do i love
it when it's i love the beginning of the
month and for it to fall on a [__]
monday ooh
my dick is really [__] hard this is
when i go to [__] work guys obviously
you could tell i'm doing a lot better
thank you for hanging in there with me
a lot of people took off regardless of
the last eight years
we've spent together you know what i'm
saying listen man this is what happened
we did a podcast for [__] nine years
me and felicia did one for one me and
lee did one for eight i decided it was
time for a [__] change and mood
moved and after all the sweat after all
the drugs i did
after people after all the drugs i did
for you people
you people what are you talking about
italian no you people now they say
[__] the saint to saint that movie
whatever the [__] the irishman you
people you know what you said you people
we gotta take care of you people if i
did all those drugs for you people i did
[__] ketamine for you [__]
i did acid with arya i had to smell his
jew feet or [__] night at least i had
flies
i come here i get a little down on
myself
i have a [__] mishap and you people
say i'm not funny no more and you fly
the coop and you leave me [__]
i'm happy you [__] left go [__]
yourselves you didn't give anybody a
chance
you got to take the lows listen bro you
know what a real [__] person who
loves a band is
you gotta take the highs and the lows
with that band
you know
it's not like i sat here and was trying
to be something i i couldn't be or
didn't want to be i couldn't do it i was
all [__] up my head was all [__] up
i had ptsd i was withdrawn i had [__]
20 things going on plus the shock of
moving you know i'm saying i couldn't
even [__] talk guys i couldn't even
improvise it was it was horrible i lost
my timing
i lost it all but you know what i could
have just quit and went under a [__]
couch and said [__] it i said nah i'm
gonna keep [__] pushing
i did what i had to do and we're [__]
here you know what i'm saying
again i had a point to [__] prove
i had something to [__] prove i had
to prove it to myself that i could still
do this
dumb [__] and come on here and giggle
with you [__] once a week
without smoking pot or eating 20 million
[__] edibles can you guys believe
that i'm down to seven joints a week
i used to smoke seven joints in three
[__] hours
i'm down to seven
joints a [__] week that
it just blows me my [__]
it just blows me the [__] away
you know when i haven't changed i'm
still the greasy [__] that i
always was you know i just tape it down
a little bit i'm a little older we got a
house now we got a studio but i'm going
to talk to mike today we're going to
be uh we're going to start expanding a
little bit and doing some [__]
things differently i see some changes
coming maybe in january i will keep you
[__] posted on it
uh and that's it man i was just really
happy about what happened
saturday with the ufc because
the one thing that we always strive for
is yes success and
you know security for our families and
whatnot
but you also want to leave this [__]
planet proving a point
you know i talked to my
the guy who took me in when my mother
died he lost his wife three years ago
mike running
i was talking to him on the phone
saturday i had to
do some errands and he called to ask me
a question about some
and we were talking he was telling me
about his kids
his daughter
alexa
and his daughter lindsey
my niece that had
cancer she had went away and she's
healed now and
she's traveled ever since she's gotten
the cancer and beat it
her and her sister lindsay and their
husbands and boyfriends they set a goal
every 90 days and they do something they
travel they they go to a certain
restaurant they they go to a beach you
know and
and she said that after she got cancer
they had to do that because
they all had a talk you know like mike
after wife died and all this [__]
and they were saying that she
that there was things that
he wanted to do that he never did like i
told him i go you know mike we chose
cocaine
we didn't travel we didn't do any of
that [__] we didn't go to europe
we didn't do anything we [__] up we
chose cocaine
reefer we chose you know and i feel bad
about it but i don't it's a decision i
made when i was a kid
and i'm stuck with it you know what i'm
saying but
if you're young pick something to do
every 90 days
every 90 days you want something out of
this i never even got this
i never did half those things taking
little trips you know i travel because
of comedy i didn't travel because
i wanted to [__] travel over there
i'm happy i went to places like
i was watching the columbus
ohio state game the other night and i
looked at that
[__] stadium in ohio state with the
red
and
you know guys that's the [__] that i
love
you know i didn't go to college i didn't
play [__] college sports but
if i regret that's a regret not going to
college not being a part you know who
gives a [__] you paint your face you
take your shirt off you put some [__]
cologne on your nipples and you go to a
game and act like a [__] jerk off
with a bunch of other people who gives a
[__] but i always i was i always had a
stick in my ass like i was always like
not too good to go down to a stadium and
take your shirt off and jump up and down
and cheer for a team like i always
thought it was [__] stupid no i don't
no i don't if i would have done that i
would have never been involved in
cocaine for 30 [__] years
you know that's the [__] i would have
been doing so
even at 58 now i'm starting to look at
my life and going yeah i accomplished a
lot of things
i went to hollywood with what they
taught me in north bergen and guess what
that'd suck my dick they sucked my
[__] dick in hollywood i did movies i
did tv i did soap operas i did voice
overs i [__] accomplished my goals i
proved my [__] point and guess what i
didn't have to prove it to the joneses
i'd have to prove it to all those dumb
[__] bookers that would tell me no
i was too fat i was too old i was too
dirty guess who i proved to i proved my
point to me
that's the most important person you
have to prove your point to
so i don't care what you take out of
this podcast
the name of this podcast today is
proving a point
that's what you're going to do with your
life
prove a [__] point guess who did that
with their life your uncle [__]
joy but i didn't have to prove it to
those people in north bergen of those
people in [__] hollywood until my
ex-wife with her [__] [__] and
all these other people pointed their
[__] fingers when i was [__] up and
i went to prison i had a great [__]
time i was thinking about halloween in
prison the other night we had a [__]
good time but listen
i just want to tell you something if you
take anything from today's podcast
it's about proving your [__]
point you did it
who gives a [__] you're not doing it to
impress nobody i'm not looking to
impress nobody
i don't give a [__] if i ever do [__]
stand-up comedy again
i don't give a [__] if i ever do another
movie again i don't give a [__] if i do
a tv show again i did it
i toppled it off with a
guy in a movie that i wanted to work for
for years i hit it to 30 [__] years i
did other movies that i never dr i never
dreamed of doing these things you think
when i started coming i'm like one day
i'm gonna be in a [__] theater i'm
gonna show them no
no i just kept working and i just kept
[__] going you know what let's try
this goal
let's see if we could sell out one night
at a club you guys remember this all
started with the brayer improv doing one
night a month
one night a month for about three years
i started with eight people coming to
the shows then i went up to 12 then i
went up to 15 then i went up to 31. then
i started figuring out how to pot how to
[__] lie to people and [__] come on
down lindsay lohan will be there they're
bringing blows she's giving out blow
jobs people would actually come to brag
on where's lindsay lohan it was [__]
tremendous guys did she bring blow it
was [__] crazy and then [__] he
cut my deal because it was 400 guarantee
then they said cut it you're gonna have
to do 100 of the door you know what that
means guys that you started [__] zero
so when i tell mike that i'm going to
pay him 100 when i tell lee i'm going to
pay him 100 to come down and do the show
i'm not going to know till i get there i
might have to hit the atm and lose money
out of my own pocket that's how i
learned how to [__] promote and then
i hooked up with my agent and he started
booking me on the road and i started
selling out one night one show let's saw
one show then two shows then three shows
oh [__] we sold out friday late because
friday late nobody wants to see you
friday late they're dying they're drunk
and they want to get their dick sucked
they gotta go to work saturday morning
guess what you start selling off friday
late night you move up to [__]
theaters and so on and so forth i proved
my [__] point yeah i went to prison
yeah i did a lot of shitty things as a
kid but i turned my life around i looked
in the mirror one day and i go you know
what
i don't care about this i don't care
about that i don't care about status i
don't care about a porsche i just want
to prove my [__] point
i drive a subaru by the way anyway
i love you [__] at all my heart
thank you very much
for watching to join we did it all the
way to [__] november 1st and just
remember this month when you start
journaling and stuff it's a whole new
set of goals and
remember
start that page where you're going to
[__] prove your [__] point whether
you have a band whether you're an artist
whether you're a roller skater whether
you're a comedian or just want to suck
coccy you want to break the record in
the [__] uh whatever i love you
[__] have a great week
stay black and i'll be wet i'll be back
wednesday morning tip top magoo with
another episode of the joint i love you
[__] now that is here for a word
my [__] sponsor jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much
for supporting the joint today listen
the joint is brought to you by
zip recruiter you can do almost anything
with just a click of the button listen
to me
it all starts with ziprecruiter.com
easy whether you're looking to hire or
you're looking for a job zip recruiters
got you covered when you create a free
profile with zip recruiter they send you
jobs that match your skills and
experience when you're looking for help
with zip recruiter
just go out
they send you
all the applicants you need the great
applicants after they scan everything
you can apply to most jobs that zip
recruiter sends you with just one click
no more failing applications it's that
easy it's amazing that you can do
anything with just one click on
ziprecruiter and now you could do more
you could find a job that you love
like i said create a pre profile with
zip recruiter and they'll say send you
jobs that match your skills and
experience so let
zip recruiter make your job search
easier sign up for free today joey what
do you mean free free it's monday i show
up for free [__] on monday
ziprecruiter.com
slash capital e a s y it's easy because
it's easy
zip recruiters got a ton of jobs on
there if you're seriously looking for a
job ziprecruiter's gonna help you once
again go to ziprecorder.com
easy right now to sign up absolutely
free and put zip recruiter to work for
you
the joint is also brought to you by
liquid iv
i'm drinking some right now as we speak
the guava
is tremendous let me tell you something
i got turned down to liquid iv and i
reached out to them that's how good this
product is that's what i've been doing
lately when i like something i feel is
great
you know what else anything to get you
healthy flu season is here you got to
stay hydrated to support your immune
system adding one stick of liquid iv to
16 ounces of water forget about it you
hydrate faster and more efficiently than
water alone
i love
liquid iv i drink it at the gym while
i'm working out to keep me
hydrated that was what they've been
talking about since day one of this
pandemic was to stay hydrated my
favorite flavors of the tangerine i go
back and forth and the guava
okay let me explain something to you
i feel great i'm sleeping better i'm
healthier no more sugary sports drink no
more artificial flavors of preservatives
and less sugar than an apple you can't
beat it so made with clean ingredients
it's not gmo
vegan gluten-free dairy-free and
soy-free
and they're a great company i love
immune support i'll tell you why
they supporting frontline work is to
stay healthy liquid iv has donated to
hospitals food banks veterans and active
military 11 million servings have been
donated and counting
and just for the listeners to the joint
grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you get them
delivered like i do
get 25 off when you go to liquid
iv.com use code joey at checkout again
25 off when you go to liquidive.com
use code joey at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you promo code
joey at liquidity liquidity.com try the
mango i'm not the mango try to guava
you're gonna love it the tangerine is
tremendous
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings this is the week [__]
this saturday live from new york you got
usman versus covington round two it's
gonna be [__] the nightmare against
kr
squaring off in the octagon i got
something for you [__] during
ufc 268 five dollars can net you two
hundred dollars with draftking
sportsbook again bet five dollars you
win you get 203
picks with draftking sportsbook new
customers bet five hours on either
fighter and you win 203 bets oh ufc is
not for you how about some [__]
blackjack you could play football
blackjack you have to have live dealer
they have poker bacca rock draftkings is
safe secure reliable plus they have the
best payouts in the [__]
business best of all you can withdraw
your cash whenever the [__] you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
today right now right now download the
draftking sportsbook
use promo code joey if gamble ain't you
or they don't have it in your sp in your
state download the draftkings fantasy
app they're giving away millions of
dollars in [__] prizes they enter
pools for [__] free to win like five
thousand dollars and you use code joey
with that one too but this saturday it's
code joey this saturday at draftking
sportsbook
with of the official sports betting
partner of the ufc
[__] draftkings you got to be
21 older new jersey indiana pa only new
customers only
minimum 5 hour deposit with a dollar
wager required and again don't be cute
one customer don't be using [__]
aliases restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details
you got a gambling prom take a breather
call 1-800 gambler work the steps
but if you're ready to [__] party
draftkings is ready too let's download
the draftking sportsbook app and let's
win some [__] guitars tip top
magoo i want to thank liquid iv
i want to thank zip recruiter and i want
to thank the official betting partner of
the ufc
draftkings i love you [__] stay
black have a great day
i'll see you guys wednesday tip top
[__] magoo
stay black
[Music]
you